Saturn. Auf dem Areal 51 ist es zu Auseinandersetzungen gekommen zwischen den blauen Saturbewohnern und den roten Saturnbewohnern. Die Ursache ist bislang ungeklärt, auch wer die grossen Stromkabel durchgeschnitten hat. Wir schalten nun zu unserem Reporter Gustav Fresel, der dort live von dem Gasgiganten berichtet.
Gustav, was kannst du über die aktuelle Situation sagen?
Gustav?
Schönen guten Tag. Ja, also die Situation ist bislang noch ein wenig umgekehrt.
Jetzt haben wir kein Signal hier leider.
Entschuldigung.
Ich stehe hier direkt vor den durchgeschnittenen riesengroßen Stromabeln.
Wir sehen, dass Sie reden, aber wir haben leider keinen Ton.
Verstehe. Verstehe, ja. Gustav, wir hören Sie nicht, wir kommen später noch mal zu Ihnen. Vielen Dank. Ja, zu Sport. Der Planetsport ist noch relativ jung und wurde jetzt erst entdeckt. Die ersten Reklimatisierungsvorhaben haben begonnen. Ob es auf diesem Planetensport Leben geben kann, das wissen wir noch nicht. Die erste Analyseergebnisse haben bereits ergeben, dass geringe Mengen H2O dort vorhanden sein könnten, in welcher Form, gasförmig, flüssig oder worauf wir hoffen, als Eis, ist noch nicht klar. Kommen wir nun zum Wetter mit Bernhard Brinkler. Diamantenregen auf dem Neptun hier zur später Stunde, ansonsten die Temperaturen in den Abendstunden bewegen sich bis im hohen 500 Kelvin Bereich. Dort ist lieber nicht damit zu rechnen, dass sie rausgehen, ansonsten auf der Venus natürlich holen sie sich einen Schirm, auch hier wieder Säureregen den ganzen Tag, wie die letzten 600.000 Jahre auch schon. Vielen Dank.
Und jetzt noch zum Abschluss die Lottozahlen für morgen Dienstag, den 23. Kolumbialist des vierten Zeitalters.
Pi, Pi durch zwei, Omega und E Quadrat und Wurzel K.
Wir wünschen Ihnen viel Erfolg, diese Angaben sind wie immer ohne Gewehr. Din, din, din, din, din, din. Wann wurden eigentlich diese Nachrichtenintros so episch? Also irgendwann hat es so angefangen mit Bip, Bip, Bip, hier ist die BBC, hier kommt das der Gragram aus London. Genau, so ein Morse, daher kommt es ja. Ach, Moment mal, da ist noch gemorst eine Nachricht drin oder was? Nein, nein, nein, mir kam nur gerade der... Das heißt, warte mal, ich übersetze das mal. Herzlich willkommen zu Tagesbau, da ist ein Rechtsreiffehler drin. Aber ich... Vermorst. Also was ich glaube gerade, fiel mir aber auch erst beim Sprechen ein, so ist es manchmal, dass die Uralten, da kam ja dieses, das ist ja immer so, das vermischt man ja so ein bisschen mit dem. Das ist Gigi D'Agostino? Ja genau, das ist David Garrett. Und ich glaube, das soll natürlich auch ein bisschen erinnern, assoziieren, alte Telegramme. Wiesen Ticker, ja, stimmt.
Telegrafen, was ja so ein bisschen das ist und klar, damit kam ja die News früher rein, also es macht schon Sinn, inzwischen einfach nur Epicness, pure Epicness, Gandalf hat die Söldner, die Geistersöldner bekommen und rennt jetzt auf Helms Klamm, also so klingt ja ein bisschen das Tagesthema. Ja, warum nicht den Chor? Warum nicht mal so 100 Japaner da hinstellen und so Tagesschau, das ist die Tagesschau, ihr wollt die News bekommen, ihr kriegt die News sofort, das ist die Tagesschau. Schlechte Nachrichten überall. Und dann denkt man auch, Jesus Christ ist das Kolonial. ARD und ZDF versuchen sich immer so eins zu überbieten in der Epischness. Finde ich schon gut. Aber ist es ein Urban Legend, dass Hans Zimmer die neue Tagesschau-Melodie geschrieben hat? Ja. Nee, ich glaube nämlich nicht. Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Ich weiß es nicht, gar nicht. Musst der denn nebenbei noch Sachen komponieren? Ich dachte, der hat es langsamer ausgesorgt, der gute Hans. Oder kriegt der den Rachen auch nicht voll? Der soll mal, finde ich, den Platz freimachen für viele Nachwuchskompositeure, die da auch noch mal was von der Partitur abhaben. Ja, zum Beispiel? Zwei Akkorde. Ja, man sagt, der komponiert das gar nicht selber, sondern irgendwelche anderen. Valentin hat das Intro für uns heute gemacht. Vielen, vielen Dank. Valentin und wahrscheinlich sein Ghostwriter. Fünfkörperliches Ghostwriter-Team.
Oder Hans Zimmer ist sein Ghostwriter, wissen wir auch nicht genau.
Vielleicht dreht das dann einfach um.
Das kann gut sein. Ich meine, du weißt, wie es ja ist, wenn man
einen grossen Namen hat, wie man dann
in der Öffentlichkeit auftritt. Alles soll plötzlich genial
sein, du als genialer Autor, wenn mal
irgendwie jemand eine frische Nachricht bei Tinder schickt,
erwarten alle sofort, dass da jetzt
irgendwie hier Günter Grass um die Ecke
kommt. Währenddessen ist es meistens so ein High, was geht. Dann ist die Enttäuschung groß. Aber brichst du bewusst auch damit, dass wenn Leute dir irgendwie clevere Fragen stellen oder sowas mit sehr viel Relativsetzen und Fremdwörtern, dass du dann bewusst einfach damit brichst, weil Leute den genialen Florentin will. Ja, doch, natürlich. Du musst die Erwartungen immer wieder neu brechen, um wirklich ein neues Bild auch von dir aufbauen zu können. Aber dann bist du ungreifbar, dann bist du ein Fisch. Ich werde greifbar. Also ich zerbrösel quasi in Echtzeit, um dann greifbar zu werden, um dann aus dem Sand der Persönlichkeit neue Burgen aufbauen zu können. Also der Phönix aus der Asche entsteht, du brichst dich immer wieder selbst, inzwischen kommt dann doch hervor, wer Florentin wirklich ist. Ich verstehe es als eine Art Vererdung. Also ich löse mich in Erde auf, aus denen dann die nächste Pflanze wieder wachsen kann, die dann vielleicht noch schöner und grösser, aber auch anschaubar ist. Okay, und was ist das für ein Mensch? Das ist eine Sonnenblume. Das ist eine schöne Sonnenblume, wo auch die Kinder rankommen und da so die Samen rausknibbeln können. Also ich bin alles ... Die Kinder sollen da die Samen rausknibbeln? Das ist im Sinne von Sonnenblumenkerne. Nee, aber nach Ihrem letzten ... Sie wissen, warum Sie in der Kritik stehen und warum man sich ... Also Sie haben die neue Chance bekommen, in der Öffentlichkeit zu stehen. Herr Zimmer, freut mich, dass Sie jetzt so ... Jetzt sollen die Kinder in die Samen rauskitzeln. Nein, die köstlichen Sonnenblumenkerne, die Sie doch auch so gerne essen. Jesus. Entschuldigung, das ist ... Christ. Herr Zimmer, ich muss Ihnen auch mal sagen, Sie versuchen, sich hier neu zu erfinden mit dieser Talkshow, mit dieser Jugend-Talkshow. Jesus Christ. Ja, Holy Moly, ja, ja, ja. Holy Smokes. So, aber ich glaube nicht, dass Ihnen das steht, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das ist eine Frack, der nicht passt. Digga, ich entscheide selbst, welche Frack-Frecke dann doch zu mir passten. Ah, holy shit. Also wir haben ein paar Nachrichten bekommen für die letzten Folgen. Gebündelt, was, also alle fünf Folgen, die letzten fünf abgearbeitet? Ne, wir haben ein paar Nachrichten bekommen für die letzten Folgen. Gebündelt, was, mal so alle fünf Folgen, die letzten fünf abgearbeitet? Ne, wir haben ein paar Themen gehabt, wo wir gerade beim Thema Kinder waren. Es gibt Babymassagen. Wir hatten das Thema Kindermassagen aufge... Es ist aufgekommen, es ist passiert. Es kam einfach so, es war ein Jux, es war ein Jux, wir haben uns kaputt gelacht, ich weiß nicht, euren Reaktionen da draußen nach nicht, also weil keine kam, ausser halt da ist es, weil wir haben gefragt, gibt es das denn wirklich, hoffentlich nicht, nein, gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht, wir haben zumindest keine Beweise bekommen, aber es gibt Babymassagen, das heißt Babys werden massiert, damit ihre Schlecke, weil die ja immer, kennt man ja, der ganze Stress zieht den Nacken und dann zieht er so hoch. Ja, da kommt das Baby von der Abwehr so, oh jetzt, Ruben, kannst du mich nochmal durchkneten bitte, das war. Oh, was hast du wieder gemacht, hast du wieder zu viel malocht, ne? Ach ja, weißt du, dieser Quadrat muss da in das Quadrat rein und das Dreieck, da sitze ich stundenlang dran, ne, jetzt schalt erst mal ab, knet ruhig ordentlich überall durch, knet ruhig überall, keine Grenzen heute, Ruben, du, knet ruhig überall. Jetzt hör mal zu, wenn die dir zu viele Rätsel geben, dann leg das weg, du musst ja nicht alles machen. Ach ja, du, ich... Ne, hör mal zu, du musst ja nicht alles machen. Ja, Mensch, du hast recht, Ruben, du, ich denk da immer dran, aber dann denk ich mir, Mensch, da lass ich mir den Stress doch lieber wegkneten von dir, du. Ich knete den Stress auch weg, macht ja da mal keinen Kopf, ne, guck mal, du bist ja ganz verspannt, aber ich sag nur, Jo, fang mal an, du. Ich sag nur, das Memory, ne, das kannst du auch lecklassen, das kannst du morgen machen, ne, an dem du machst heute nur die Form, machst du blau in blau, grün in grün, rot in rot, ne, das kannst du machen. Du kannst das immer, du, komm mal ran hier und auch gerne mal unter die Windel, du, wenn du verstehst, also. Komm, jetzt kapp dich doch nicht so, Mensch. Wir kennen uns doch schon lange.
Nee, der muss nicht professionell bleiben.
Ach, wir kennen uns doch schon lange.
Nee, klar kennen wir uns lange. Wir kennen uns jetzt seit drei Monaten, also dein ganzes Leben praktisch.
Für mich ist das eine Ewigkeit.
Nee, der muss nicht professionell bleiben. Du, ich mag dich auch gerne. Du bist ein guter Kerl, du bist ein dufter Kerl.
Aber ich kann das nicht machen.
Nein, jetzt hör doch mal auf.
Jetzt weint doch nicht. Äääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääää immer direkt auf 100. Also da gibt es kein Antasten, mal irgendwie so eine Emotion aufbauen, so dramaturgisch mal was steigern lassen, sondern immer direkt... Also, ja, okay, kurzen Anlauf gibt es schon, aber dann wirklich auf hundert so, also direkt im Ruheabteil, immer so auch direkt, nicht mal so ein, sondern einfach immer direkt all in, als würde direkt die Welt untergehen. Ich glaube, es ist schwer einzuschätzen bei einem Kind, ob jetzt wirklich was ein Problem ist oder ob jetzt einfach nur gerade mal langweilig ist. Ich bin jetzt dreimal mit der Bahn gefahren in den letzten Wochen, also die letzten drei von vier Bahnfahrten jeweils nach Berlin hin waren der absolute Horror. Und ich weiß, klar, Podcasts sind nicht mehr bahnlustig, aber es ist so schlimm gewesen. Und ich glaube, du wärst ein anderer Mensch gewesen.
Weil ich kann das so ausschalten.
Okay, ich nicht anscheinend.
Nee, nee, nee, du machst dann Petitionen und sowas.
Aber ehrlich gesagt war ich dann auch kurz davor.
Willst du schreiben, wir brauchen noch welche?
Wir brauchen auch noch eine Menge Unterschriften.
Aber bevor man sich darüber quasi aufregt, dass ...
Ich bin jetzt abgekommen. Ich bin jetzt der Meinung, unterschreibt diese Petition nicht mehr, sondern konzentriert euch auf andere Baustellen bei der Bahn. Also willst du eine eigene Gegenpetition aufmachen, um meiner auch die Stimmen abzugraben? Nein, nein, ich will dir die Stimmen nicht abgraben. Ich denke mir nur, lass uns doch mal ... Da hast du auch für dich eine Verantwortung, weil wenn die Durchsetzung des Ruheabteils unser grösstes Problem wäre, das wäre ja schön, aber da sind wir noch gar nicht. Das ist ja wie, lass uns die Häuser neu bemalen, es ist ja sonst alles perfekt in unseren Städten, die sind ja perfekt, die sind ja schön, alles läuft gut, der Verkehr ist super, lass uns jetzt die Häuser schön bunt malen. Das ist ja die Kirsche auf der Torte der logistischen Reibungslosigkeit, Aber das ist ja alles nicht gegeben. Ich habe eine Fahrt nach Berlin gestanden. Auf dem Zug drauf? Im Zug drinnen. Ach so, im Zug. Ja gut, ja, da ist ja doch okay. Fand ich ganz, ganz schlimm, dass es sein musste. Du bist ein großer Mensch, du musst dann auch immer den Kopf so anwinkeln, weil du sonst nicht da reinpasst. Das war schlimm, aber nicht das Schlimmste, sondern habe ich mich dann, weil auch die Gänge alle voll waren, musste ich mich dann ins Bordbristow stellen, wo, und da habe ich schon gemerkt, weil ich habe mich auf dem Bahnkomfortplatz gesetzt. Stark. Und weil ich denke, das ist mein, ich halte mich eigentlich für ein Bahnfahrprofi inzwischen, und das ist immer mein erster Platz, wo ich denke, die Chance, dass man hier weggejagt wird, ist denkbar gering. Also selbst wenn man, es ging gar nicht mehr möglich, eine Sitzplatzreservierung zu machen für diesen Zug, im Wochenvorrag schon ausgebucht, dachte ich mir, ja, es wird ja nicht so voll sein. Man kriegt sich ja eh mal irgendwo. Fehler eins, ja. So und dann, ja genau, finde ich gut, dass du mir sagst, wo die ganzen Fehler passiert sind. Da habe ich mich auf dem Bahnkomfortplatz gesetzt, weil das ist immer, wenn man den früh ansteuert, kriegt man dann auch einen Platz, den wird oft ausgelassen, weil die Laien suchen erst nach den gegebenenfalls freigegebenen Plätzen. Grosser Fehler, aber das funktioniert nie. Das weiss sogar ich. Das bin auf dem Bahnkomfortplatz und da wurde ich noch nie weggejagt. Diesmal zum ersten Mal von jemandem, der mir eine Bahncard 100 gezeigt hat. Oh, der Trumpf. Ich habe kurz noch versucht, ja, aber das ist ja keine Bahn-Comfort-Karte,
und er hat mir diesen Blick gegeben, diesen,
oh Gott, willst du mir jetzt sagen, wie es ist? Und da bin ich sofort aufgestanden und habe mich ins Boardbistro
gestellt. Der entwaffnende Blick.
Und da habe ich schon gemerkt, die zwei Minuten,
in denen ich saß, oh Gott, da ist irgendwie eine
weirde Stimmung im Boardbistro, weil
da war so ein super lustiger
Kellner unterwegs.
Und das war dann mein persönlicher Horror. Und du liebst ja Kellner, ne? Ich liebe ja Kellner so sehr. Und dann war ich in einem Bordbristow und da war so eine Gruppe von Leuten, Belgier, die sprachen aber alle Deutsch gesprochen und die waren und die und der Kellner hatten so einen guten Vibe. Der Kellner kam rein und hat einen Witz gemacht und die haben das habe ich noch nie in keinem Comedy-Club der Welt gesehen, wie die ausgeflippt sind. Ich sage mal, Colbert in New York, wo wir waren, kam grob dran so von der Stimmung her, aufgepeitscht und danach war man fertig, weil man so viel gelacht hat. Das mal zehn war da in den Boardbristen los und dann waren es ungefähr so Witze wie, können wir mit Karte zahlen, ich weiß nicht, wenn eine Postkarte drauf ist, sowas. Was? Ja, kann ich mit Karte zahlen, ja, wenn eine Postkarte drauf ist und... Wenn eine Postkarte... Lass uns den mal kurz... Sorry, tut mir leid, ich habe nicht versprochen. Ich habe nicht versprochen. Guck mal, und deswegen arbeitet sie nicht im Bordbistro, weil du einfach nicht die Entertainment-Qualitäten hast. Wenn eine Briefmarke... Sorry. Jesus, I'm so ... Jesus Christ.
Okay, ich komm noch mal.
Wenn eine Briefmarke drauf ist ...
Hey, sag mal, können wir eigentlich auch mit Karte zahlen?
Ja, wenn eine Postkarte drauf ist ...
Scheiss.
Was meinen Sie?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Nee, ich ... ich steck jetzt hier aus.
Hier ist meine Marke und mein Namenschild.
Meine Waffe.
Und meine Waffe und mein Tracer und mein Rührei. R. Raus. Nee, er hat, sorry, tut mir leid. Nochmal, einmal noch. Er hat gesagt, alle guten Gags sind drei. Kann ich auch mit Karte zahlen? Ja, wenn eine Briefmarke drauf ist. Große Lacher. Habe ich jetzt auch nicht hundertprozentig gestanden. Ich auch nicht. Furchtbar. Aber Leute haben sich kaputt gelacht. Und das musste ich dann für vier Stunden stehend ertragen. Also das war nun... Und ehrlich gesagt, er hat auch manchmal das falsch delivered und so. Also das war jetzt nicht so weit weg. Aber das war ganz nicht schlimm. Das war die erste Fahrt. Zweite Fahrt habe ich statt der angegebenen vier Stunden achteinhalb Stunden gebraucht, weil es einen Unfall gab und die Bahn nicht in der Lage war, an dem Unfall vorbeizufahren. Ja, das liegt an den Gleisen, das habe ich auch schon oft mit dem Schaffender besprochen. Pass auf, pass auf.
Kann man nicht einfach kurz ausscheren und auf die Überholspur oder so?
Und er meinte dann, nee, nee, wir sind ja auf diesen beiden Metallstangen, die ja den Weg vorgeben. Ja, verstehe ich jetzt nicht, warum wir sie nicht. Er hat mir das am Bahnsteig dann auch gezeigt und ich habe das erst nicht verstanden. Sie denken in Schranken, hätte ich mir gesagt. Ich denke in Schienen. Sie denken in Schienen, weil ihr Kopf ist eingeschränkt von ihrem, lösen Sie sich doch mal von diesem Schienengedanken. Ja, ja, ja, das ist nur technisch leider nicht so ganz leicht zu machen. Ne, Flontien, jetzt hör mal auf mit deinem Klugscheissertum, weil der Unfall war sechs Stunden vorher passiert und schon als wir in Köln losgefahren sind, hätten die theoretisch ja, es gibt ja nicht nur drei Bahnstrecken in Deutschland,
drumrum fahren können.
Nein, war nicht möglich, acht und eine halbe Stunde da gesessen,
dass dann schon so irgendwann Getränke ausgeteilt wurden,
kostenlos, weil es allen ...
Oh ja, ich liebe diese Notstandssituation,
wo man dann sagt, okay, jetzt wird's ernst, holt das Tetra-Wasser.
Jetzt sind wir kurz davor von dem Bürgerkrieg, jetzt noch mal ...
Und ich weiss nicht, wer das entscheidet in der Crew, wo sie dann zusammenkommen in dem War Room und dann alle so, okay. Situation Room. Okay. Okay, was haben wir für News an der Front im Wagen 93? Also wir haben Podcaster im Bordbistro, das Ganze fliegt uns spätestens nächste Woche komplett um die Ohren, ganz Deutschland weiss davon. Wir haben noch versucht, unseren lustigen Kellner reinzuschicken, der scheint die ganze Sache gerade zu beruhigen. Ansonsten schreiendes Kind in Zug eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs und sieben. Die ploppen überall gerade so auf, sind rot. Bringt das Notstandswasser raus. Das Notstandwasser. Den einzigen Knopf, den sie haben, den sie drücken können. Ja, alle so, überall gehen so die Schotten dicht, alle so auf und überall und alle so mit dem Wasser tragen. Thank you for traveling with Deutsche Bank. Nee, für mich nicht, danke. Okay. Ich habe Silberwasser, danke schön. Können wir nicht machen. Ja, es ist schwierig. Das war das eine. Da muss man durch. Und dann war ich gestern, das hast du auch schon mal erzählt, über die Situation, der Zug ist zu voll. Wir können nicht weiterfahren. Das ist das Schlimmste. Und ich war im Ruheabteil und neben mir war ein schreiendes Kind. Deswegen kam ich gerade drauf. Wurde so ein Kinderwagen, wurde genau neben mich geschoben. Und das fing ab, mich so angeguckt. Und dann im Ruheabteil.
Und die Eltern haben gesagt,
nee, wir haben eigentlich hinten irgendwo im Familienabteil einen Platz,
aber ja, da können den andere Leute haben, jetzt sitzen wir ja hier, haben wir einen Platz gefunden.
Ich dachte mir so, ja, aber es hat ja einen Sinn.
Wahrscheinlich habt ihr euch mal Gedanken gemacht, warum wir im Familienabteil...
Und dann standen da...
Ja, glaube ich, ja, da wäre ich... Also nicht sofort, aber zehn Minuten danach hätte ich dann schon mal meinen Mut zusammengefasst und gesagt, jetzt ist mein Schuh. Und vor allem war das genau die, weil ich habe meine Kopfhörer verloren und musste dann die sechs Stunden ohne Kopfhörer... Was war das denn für eine Reise? Ja. Bist du auf dem Weg zum Bahnhof hingefallen, oder was? Nein, die sind einfach verloren. Die sind einfach weg. Ich glaube, die wurden mir aus der Tasche geklaut, aus meinen riesengroßen Taschen. Wurden die mir geklaut, während ich orientierungslos. Du hast ja grosse Taschen, ne? Du trägst ja immer diese ganz weiten Jeans, die dann auch so diese ganz grossen Hosentaschen haben. Also da könnte man wirklich einen ganzen Kürbis reinkriegen, weil du hast immer so diese riesigen Ausladen-Taschen, die gerade wenn sie leer sind, auch so nach außen fallen, wo du dann wirklich auch immer überall anstößt und immer überall an Türklinken festhängst und so. Es steht dir, es ist ja dein Stil, so kennen wir dich ja, aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das manchmal ein Sicherheitsrisiko ist. Ja, Form voraus Function sollte ich mir vielleicht eher umsetzen, in dem Sinne, dass man eine Funktion, eine Hose sein sollte, es darf nicht geklaut werden. Also wieder Skinny Jeans jetzt. Gib mir die Skinniest of all Jeans. Ja, ich habe ja immer in meinem Rucksack eine Pfeile dabei. Und ihr kennt ja alle das Klischee Pink Panther, Tim und Struppi. Wir reden von Nagelpfeile, nicht von Legolas Pfeile, richtig? Ja, und ihr kennt ja immer das Klischee, dass irgendwie Tim und Struppi. Wir reden von Nagelpfeile, nicht von Legolas-Pfeile, richtig?
Ja.
Und ihr kennt ja immer das Klischee, dass irgendwie Tim und Struppi sitzt im Gefängnis, irgendwie Tabaluga oder so. Und dann kriegt er so eine Torte mit einer Feile drin. Und auch als Kind dachte ich mir schon, bin kein Experte für Sicherheitstechnik und Strafvollzug und so. Was genau soll da jetzt passieren? Die Idee ist, man säbelt damit langsam, drückend langsam die Stäbe durch.
Weil früher waren die Pfeilen noch aus härterem Material als die Gittertüren. Ja, und ich dachte mir immer schon als Kind, das ist doch Quatsch, gib dem doch eine dicke Zange oder eine Schere oder irgendwie sowas.
Und jetzt musste ich allerdings feststellen, dass die Pfeile tatsächlich eine fucking Macht ist. Das ist eine fucking Macht. Weil ich hatte immer die Pfeile in der Tasche vor meinem Rucksack und die hat langsam den Boden weggefeilt, so dass ich eines Tages meinen Rucksack, weil ich habe immer meinen Schlüssel im Rucksack vorne in der Tasche, so dass ich eines Tages meinen Rucksack weggenommen habe von dem Stuhl und da lag noch mein Schlüssel. Und ich dachte mir, oh shit, habe ich den da daneben gelegt oder was? Pack den ein, merke, dass diese Pfeile ausgebrochen ist, Prison Break, ist die ausgebrochen aus dem Rucksack. Und dein Rucksack ist aus Granit, muss man auch noch so sagen. Absolut, da kommt eigentlich nichts durch. Und das heißt, dieser Schlüssel hätte genauso gut in jeder anderen Situation des Alltags einfach random rausfallen können und ich wäre komplett verloren gewesen, ich hätte ihn nie wieder gefunden. Also da bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte Leute, mehr Respekt vor Feilen. Wir alle nehmen Feilen nicht ernst genug, wir alle denken, was soll da passieren, aber das ist wirklich über lange Zeit. Die stete Feile feilt den Stein. Bitte, bitte, bitte mehr Respekt.
Aber wird auch nicht abgenommen im Flughafen. Das ist mir noch nie passiert, dass eine Weltfeile rausgerissen wurde. Ich musste die Pfeile sogar ablegen, als ich aus der Kirche ausgetreten bin. Der hiesse es dann so, da hat der Ministrant da vorne am Amt, meinte dann so, aber ohne Pfeile. Und dann musste ich extra die Pfeile ablegen. Gut, weil das damals fast ein Kommunionsgeschenk war. Gut, das war jetzt auch eine, sag ich mal, recht große, ich habe sehr grosse Fingernägel, muss man dazu sagen. Also übernatürlich groß. Die würden gut in meine Hosentasche passen. Das stimmt, ja. Naja, Kirchenaustritt. Und ich habe die ganze Zeit, als ich dann dieser Beamtin gegenüber saß, habe ich wirklich im Bild gehabt, wie ich der mit der Feile so in die Kehle steche, einfach so, wo ich mir denke, was ist jetzt das Schlimmste, was mit dieser Feile passiert. Erst was mir dann einfällt, desto supernatural mässig so ein Dämon dann aus ihr rauskommt. Oh ja, genau. Aber ist ja eigentlich falsch, da müsste ja Engel aus ihr rauskommen. Und vielleicht kann man Engel gut mit Feilen besiegen, deswegen sagen die im Vorhinein, nee, nee. Amors, Amors Feile. Amor. Ich wurde von Amors Feile durchgesäbelt, sagt man ja dann auch ab und zu. Gibt es wieder freie Termine für Kirchenaustritte in Köln, habe ich gerade aufs Ohr bekommen. Jetzt kommt der Service-Teil, ein schönes Risotto-Rezept da hinterher. Steffans Service-Te Serviceteil. Ich kurz meine so ein Verbraucher. Ja, Stephans Heresie. Einfach so kommt ihr aus dem Himmel raus. Ja. Kurz mal einmal, also das gibt es wieder. Meldet euch an in Köln. Ich weiß nicht, wie es in anderen Städten ist. Wahrscheinlich räumt es sich da auch gerade wieder ein bisschen auf. Am Amt. Schaut mal vorbei und tritt doch aus der Kirche aus. Habt da die 30 Euro dabei, die sind nicht trivial, die braucht ihr. Mit Karte kann man glaube ich nicht zahlen, unbedingt. Und ja, denkt an die Thesen. Wenn auch ihr noch was mehr verändern wollt, klappt, ballert die Thesen an. Müssen nicht immer 99 sein, können aber fünf sein. Oder hundert, mach die hunderten mal voll.
Was meinst du, wie viele Thesen hatte Luther und hat sich dann gedacht, habe ich sieben und achzig, kriege ich noch zwölf weitere hin für neunneunzig oder war das wirklich Zufall, dass es wirklich neunneunzig war? Weil man kennt jetzt ja, jeder kennt, jeder hat schon mal eine Top-Ten-List geschrieben und man hat vielleicht so vier Sachen oder so und dann muss man, kann man das noch irgendwie zweiteteil. Jeder hat schon mal den Satz angefangen. So, drei Dinge. Erstens, und man hat eigentlich nur einen Punkt,
weil man hatte mal zwei beim Denken, hat gedacht, ich werde mir noch einen finden, hat doch noch aber eher den anderen vergessen. Und es waren 95 Thesen. Uuuuh, snap, nicht schlecht, der coole Protestant. Jetzt komme ich heute Abend, ich laufe heute Abend mit so einem Grinsen ein. Ja, ichen ein. Du hast gerade gegoogelt. Habe ich richtig gut gegoogelt heute. Ich habe heute Florenti mal wieder richtig gut weggegoogelt. Ich habe ihn einfach weggegoogelt. Naja, nachdem du in den letzten Folgen ab und zu mich so vorführen wolltest, oder so als Unsympathie darstellen wolltest, ich weiß nicht, ob du das gerade ehrlich gesagt nicht wieder bestätigt hast. Ich habe es jetzt, dich vorzuführen mit meinen Google-Attacken, um mein Image wiederherzustellen. Aber interessant. 95, da muss auch viel Crab dabei gewesen sein. Ja, aber so viel Crab, dass man dann denkt, dann wiederhol doch die vier nochmal. Ja. Also, da kommst du wenigstens auf. Vor Vor allem weißt du, die anderen haben zehn Gebote und er sagt, weißt du was, 95.
Leute, das ist doch ein bisschen, mach doch elf oder dreizehn oder so, das wäre doch cool gewesen.
Aber gibt es die noch, gibt es da Fotos, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber Überlieferungen von, wie die dann so geschrieben, war da Rechtschreibfehler drin?
Hat er sich mal so richtig dusselig verschrieben?
Das kann sein, ja.
Stell dir vor, du bist bei These 93 und schreibst dann irgendwie Gott irgendwie mit drei oder so was oder zwei O. Und denkst dir, oh Gott, ich töne. Ja, ja. Ich meine, ich habe so eine Hipster-Schreibmaschine geschenkt bekommen von einem Kumpel, mit der... Aber ich muss gar nichts machen, um dich unsympathisch zu machen. Du machst das ja ganz alleine. Ich habe das ganz alleine. Und es wäre trotzdem schön, wenn die Leute einfach selber ihr Bild bilden könnten und du nicht von weg suggestiv schon sagst, dass es eine unsympathische Eigenschaft ist. Und damit schreibe ich dann manchmal so Weihnachtskarten oder so was. Oder wenn ich was schenke, schreibe ich dazu dann so eine Karte. Und das ist schon das Nervigste der Welt, weil ich denke immer so, wow, gut, also habe ich die Person so gern, dass ich da jetzt diese Schreibmaschine raushole und denke dann immer, ja, ist ja irgendwie lustig und sieht cool aus. Und dann fange ich an zu schreiben und jedes Mal verschreibe ich mich bei Liebegrüsse Stefan oder sowas. Und es ist so schlimm, das dann nochmal machen zu müssen. Diese Delete-Taste, ihr wisst gar nicht, was das für ein Luxus ist. Ja. Was das für ein Luxus ist. Ey, Löschen ist, glaube ich, der grösste zivilisatorische Fortschritt, den es überhaupt gibt. Dinge zurücknehmen. Ja. Glaubst du, unsere Gespräche haben sich verändert, seitdem man Chats editieren kann oder zurücknehmen kann oder Dinge nicht schreiben kann? Oder, sagen wir mal, du kannst, ich glaube, wir hatten ja schon mal drüber gesprochen, aber so ein Chatprogramm, in dem der andere, die andere sieht, was du schreibst. Das war die schlimmste und schlimmste Idee aller Zeiten. Gut, dass wir das nicht umgesetzt haben. Ja, bei mir ist eher das Problem, ich habe recht dicke, wulstige, mächtige Finger. Ich habe ja gerade schon die Fingernägel angesprochen, die Finger haben sich dem angepasst natürlich. Wäre jetzt auch merkwürdig, wenn die an den kleinen Stümmelchen hängen. Ja, die sind sehr fleischig. Also stellt euch vor, ihr habt noch mal eine richtig grosse Weintraube an jeder Fingerspitze. So bin ich unterwegs im Leben. Und deswegen kommt es natürlich dementsprechend zu relativ vielen Tippfehlern, die allerdings meinen mittlerweile sehr, also ich habe mir da wirklich einen sehr netten Rechtschreibkorrekturleser besorgt, der das immer versucht zu korrigieren, aber oft auch falsch korrigiert.
Zum Beispiel hat jemand letztens ganz trocken gefragt, so, hey, hättest du 15 Uhr Zeit für ein Meeting? Und ich schreibe zurück, JAA.
Ich habe einfach zweimal das A gedrückt, ne? JAA.-A. Schick das ab, was kommt bei dem anderen an? Jas. J-A-S. Jas. Und was, wo, wie kommt das an bei der anderen Person? Passt 15 Uhr? Jas. Aber es kommt eher ... Was irgendwie so cool-lässig, irgendwie so ein bisschen ... Jupp. Ja, aber so jas. Also irgendwie so cool-sassy fast ein bisschen.
Jas.
Und kein ... Coollässig, irgendwie so ein bisschen, ja, aber so, jas, also irgendwie so cool sassy fast ein bisschen.
Und dann will ich aber, und dann weiß ich auch nicht, soll ich jetzt, oh, verschrieben. Also ich kann unmöglich das Ganze aufklären, weil das natürlich viel länger dauern würde. Oh, ich wollte nur JA schreiben, hab dann JAA geschrieben, was zu JAS wurde.
Man lässt es einfach stehen.
Man lässt es stehen, aber es kommt ja so an, wie man es gemeint hat. Gott sei Dank. Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Ja. Weiß ich nicht. Also es gibt andere Buchstaben, wo ich sagen würde, die hätten passieren können. Japp. Die wären dann schon fast negativ gewesen. Juck zum Beispiel. Da würde ich sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob Florian kommt noch. Ja. Zum Meeting. Ich weiß nicht, ob er noch kommt. Er hat Jack geschrieben. Es klingt, als wäre das etwas anderes zu tun. Bei Ja's denke ich mir so, naja, der wird schon noch kommen. Aber ich denke mir halt immer, so muss ich jetzt immer Ja's sagen. Ist das jetzt mein Ding? So diese ganzen witzigen USPs sind die nicht auch manchmal auch aus einem reinen Fehler entstanden, wo man dann nicht mehr zurückkommt, wo man einfach dann sagt, weil ich wollte Fred Feuerstein einfach auch nur Ja schreiben und dann hat er die Autokorrektur Jabba Dabba Du draus gemacht und Feuerstein so Fuck ey und jetzt jedes, jeden Tag Jab Tag Jabadadu, das ist jetzt einfach sein Ding, mit dem musst du dann jetzt auch einfach gehen. Wie uncool wäre das, wenn ich das einmal mich falsch verschrieben hätte, wenn ich aus Ja, Jabadadu gemacht hätte, also deswegen Ja, genau, deswegen musst du dann durch. Stellt euch vor, der rutscht da auf dem Dinosaurier runter und sagt Ja! Weißt du, das wäre heute unverstellbar. Wohin ging Jabba-Dabba-Du ist perfekt. Super. Ich glaube, ich beantworte jetzt alles nur noch mit Jabba-Dabba-Du. Jabba-Dabba-Du. Du, sag mal, Carina kann leider nicht. Können wir das Meeting nochmal auf 16 Uhr verschieben? Jabba-Dabba-Du? Aber auch so ganz... Jabba-Dabba-Du von mir aus. Jabba-Dabba aber du, wenn es sein muss. Ja, aber du, es ist nicht mein Lieblingstermin, aber kriegt man schon hin. Also ich würde sagen, nein, aber wenn es unbedingt sein muss, na dann, ja, aber du. Ich glaube, ich könnte mir das vorstellen. Es gibt nur eine Stimmung, in der man das sagen kann. Alle anderen wirken deplatziert.
Und ich finde es auch gut, wie es ab dem gewissen Punkt ein bisschen vernuschelt wird.
Ja, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, wenn es es häufig sagt, irgendwann wird. Weil dann sag's halt nicht, du musst es nicht sagen, wenn es dir, wenn du es nicht sagen willst, sag's lieber gar nicht, anstatt zu nuscheln, aber irgendwann etabliert sich das an.
Er sagt, Herr Thüringen, können Sie noch die Akten fertig machen bis heute, dann müssen Sie ja ein bisschen länger bleiben heute.
Ja, warte bitte. Beim Sex auch komisch. Ja, was aber du, ja, was aber du, ja, was aber du, ja, was aber du. Obwohl, da glaube ich, könnte das ... Ja, es kommt auch auf den Partnerinnen und Partner an. Ich meine, Fred Feuerschein ist sexy. Fred Feuerschein, nie eine Hose getragen in seinem ganzen fucking Leben, einfach nie.
Das ist auch ein Statement.
Es ist ein Statement von Anfang an, noch nie gemacht.
Ich denke mal, Autokorrektur war mal besser, meine Meinung nach. Die macht inzwischen komische Sachen aus Dingen.
Ich sollte mir das mal aufschreiben, aber Wörter, die so offensichtlich nur leicht falsch sind, wie Woche mit X, was man häufig dann mal schreibt oder sowas, wo man dann Vox schreibt, da werden Dinge draus gemacht, irgendwelche chemischen Begriffe oder sowas, wo man dann gar nicht mehr hinterherkommt. Und wie du schon sagst, das ist dann super anstrengend, das zu erklären und so, wo ich dann einfach nur in Grossbuchstaben dann das Wort nochmal schreibe, so nach dem Motto, ich reg mich gerade über die Autokorrektur auf.
Das ist, da schwingt dann schon viel mit, aber auch viel Wut.
Ganz schlimm ist natürlich, also ich bin ja, sage ich mal, unlizenzierter Fantasy-Autor, das ist natürlich ganz schrecklich, wenn du halt dann diese ganzen... Und ungelesener. Ein ungelesener und unveröffentlichter Fantasy-Autor, der natürlich dann ganz viele so Begriffe hat, die dann irgendwie verrückte Namen, irgendwie Gondolon oder Grosslimin oder Tollavesch oder was auch immer. Und das wird natürlich alles komplett verhunzt durch die Autokorrektur. Und dann bist du dann doch wieder irgendwie in Flötenwald und sowas und das ist dann ganz schrecklich. Was bei mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, ist, dass ich meine, mein Handy merkt, dass ich Worte immer in Caps schreibe. Und es war so lustig, weil neulich war ein Name dabei in Grossbuchstaben. Dann wird immer nicht, wenn ich schreibe, hast du schon mit M-M gesprochen, ist der in Caps. Also mein Handy macht den Namen in Caps. Ja, wie in so einem Drehbuch. Weil ich mich offensichtlich ein paar Mal aufgeregt habe über diese Person oder mit ihm geschimpft habe oder was auch immer. Ja. Oder irgendwie so spielerisch in Caps geschrieben habe. Aber inzwischen wirkt das, das Gag überträgt sich ja dann auch nicht, wenn man ihn seriös dann über ihn schreibt. Aber das Handy merkt sich auch die Emotion. Ja, ja. Also das weiß genau, ah, der mag den nicht. Nee, nee, der mag, ich weiß, nee, nee, hört mir zu, ich weiß, dass der den nicht mag, der hat den letztens angeschrieben. Aber es könnte ja auch irgendwie ein Scherz gemeint sein. Nein, das war kein Scherz. Ich war da live dabei, wie der das getippt hat. Der hat ganz ernst geguckt. Okay, dann biete direkt diesen wütenden roten Smiley an. Okay, okay. Biete den direkt dahinter an. Biete einmal bitte in Großbuchstaben an. Klar, einen Moment, confirmed.
Er macht's.
Er macht's, okay.
Ja, guck mal, ich sag doch, das ist die Emotion.
Im Handy ist so ein fünfköpfiges Team drin, was immer sich gerät. So eine Live-Regie, den er immer auf so einen Knopf drückt und sagt, Thomas in Großbuchstaben.
Ah, er drückt es wieder weg. Und Achtung fürs Emoji und Emoji. Sehr gut. Er schreibt Hand, Achtung fürs Hand-Emoji in drei verschiedenen Ausführungen. Hand-Emoji in gelb. Und Achtung und bitte. Alles klar, er überlegt. Wollen wir ihm was anbieten, wollen wir ihm ein Wort anbieten? Achtung für die Wolke, er schreibt Woche, vielleicht meint er Wolke. Ist es Wolke? Warte, warte, warte, haben wir Akten vorliegen, wie oft hat er Wolke geschrieben? 19 Mal. 19 Mal. 19 Mal, Sir, Sie machen heute übrigens wieder einen tollen Job. Ja, ja, ja, ja, störe mich jetzt nicht, ich bin gerade drin. Ich wollte fragen, ob Sie heute Abend vielleicht Lust haben auf... Jetzt nicht! Sorry. Du, Stefan, ganz kurz, könntest du vielleicht Wolke gemeint haben? Nee, die Woche. Also hast du nächste Woche Zeit, Wolke macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn. Okay, heute ist Handy wieder weird drauf. Okay, verdammt, er hat alles weggedrückt. Okay, alles oder nichts. Ich schlag ihm jetzt das nächste Wort vor. Hast du diese Woche ... Fuck, was könnte er meinen, hast du diese Woche ... Geld, ähm, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, seit Jahren mit diesem Mann, ich hab, weisst du, ich hab schon diese ganzen awkward Tinder-Sachen da durchgemacht mit dem. Ich war mit ihm, als er mich am meisten gebraucht hat, okay? Ich kenne ihn wie kein Zweiter. Sie sind der Aufgabe nicht mehr gewachsen. Der Alkohol ist ihm zu Kopf gestiegen. Das werden wir mal sehen. Der Flaschen-Emoji, das ist eine ganz platonische Geschichte zwischen uns. Der Flaschen-Emoji ist ihm zu Kopf gestiegen. Und wie Sie mit Melinda umgehen, ist nicht richtig. Wenn er Leiter ablehnt, dann ziehe ich selbstständig meinen Hut.
Okay.
Hallo Stefanie, die Autokorrektur nochmal. Könntest du vielleicht Leiter meinen als nächstes Wort?
Nein. Was ist mit dem Handy heute los? War eine schöne Zeit mit euch? Sir, geben Sie mir Ihre Maus. Geben Sie mir Ihre Maus. Hier ist meine Maus. Geben Sie mir Ihre Sonnenbrillen-Emotie. Marke, hier ist der Algorithmus. Geben Sie mir den Algorithmus. Tja, dann muss ich mir als neues Örtchen suchen.
Sir, es war eine Ehre, unter Ihnen zu arbeiten.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Aber Sie gehen so schlecht mit Frauen um.
Meine Zeit ist vorbei, die Welt hat sich weitergedreht.
Naja, ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt zu Spotify, zu den Playlists. Macht's gut. Tschüss.
BAM! Shots fired! Shots fired! Spotify, take that! Take that! Wollen Sie take that? Nein, nein, im Sinne von Everybody! Jetzt kommt nicht jetzt bald der Spotify-Rückblick. Ich glaube, ihr habt jetzt noch ein bisschen Zeit, eure musikalischen Sünden des letzten Jahres zu korrigieren. Haut jetzt noch mal ein bisschen Brahms rein, noch mal ein bisschen Jazz rein, um das Ganze noch mal so ein bisschen zu korrigieren, damit nicht irgendwie alle merken, dass ihr das ganze Jahr Kindersongs und Schnappi gehört habt. Schnie, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schnappi, schna so anders, dass es cool ist, es ist peinlich. Ja, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich bei mir auch eine Box eingerichtet, bei mir zu Hause. Und das lädt natürlich auch ein dazu, Sachen einfach mal so durchlaufen zu lassen. Also sonst so mit Kopfhörern in der Bahn hört man ja immer sehr aktiv zu. Und da kann man auch mal im Nebenraum sein, während das dann irgendwie, also ich bin dann im Westflügel, während dann der Südflügel komplett beschallt wird. Mit japanischer Spa-Musik zum Beispiel. Genau, dann denke ich mir so, ah, ich glaube so japanische Spa-Musik, das ist nochmal so ein so ein Palette-Cleanser, da kann man dann nochmal irgendwie alles nochmal löschen, indem man da irgendwie alles, alles aufräumt und so. Mal gucken, ob das klappt, ansonsten bin ich auch, habe ich Angst, das ist wie Zeugnis. Ich glaube, das ist das Nächste, was der moderne, erwachsene Mensch noch am Zeugnistag hat.
Man hat schon so eine Ahnung, in welche Richtung die meisten Fächer gehen, aber am Ende gibt es dann doch oft noch böse Überraschungen.
Es gibt viele böse Überraschungen und oft haben die Leute bessere Zeugnisse.
Also andere Leute haben bessere Zeugnisse.
Genau, die posten das dann alles.
Ist das, posten Schüler heutzutage ihre Zeugnisse?
Nein, das ist merkwürdig. Das ist ein merkwürdiger Bragg, mit dem haben wir nichts zu tun.
Naja, aber es kann ja auch ein Anti-Bragg sein, wenn du sagst, Sport wieder eine Fünf beim dummen Herrn Schneider.
Des Schneiderles Noten.
Schneiderle?
Immer des Schneiderles Noten.
Die Kids nennen ihn Schneiderle.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin 28, außen, innen drin, woher ich bin eher 26, 27 auch. Okay. Aber innen drin bin ich wirklich über 60. Nee, du hast dich echt gemacht, das liegt an deinem Elektro-Training, glaube ich. Machst du das noch, dein Elektro-Training mit dem Cyborg-Anzug, wo du ... Nein, nein, nein. Erstmal mache ich gar keinen Sport, gerade wegen Obvious Reasons. Ja, soll ich doch mal die Geschichte vom Rollerunfall erzählen?
Nein, will niemand hören, kann ich nicht.
Das habe ich ja schon vergessen.
Ja, alle vergessen das.
Ja, weil man es nicht sieht, trag doch einen Gips oder sowas,
trag doch so ein großes Schulterpolster wie so ein Space Marine oder sowas.
Ich wünsche mir wirklich eine Zeit zurück, wo ich diese Schlaufe hatte,
weil da wurde noch Rücksicht genommen auf mich.
Auch in der Bahn, alle sind so über mich gestiegen und gefallen und auf mich
und haben mich so in die Garderobe geschubst, in dem Gastrowagen und dann hing ich da so drinnen und struggle. Und das wäre alles nicht passiert, wenn ich meine Armschlaufe hätte. Das stimmt. Da haben Leute gesagt, kann ich ihnen helfen, da haben Leute wirklich gesagt, kann ich ihnen helfen, kann ich ihnen Platz anbieten und sowas. Wo ich dann dachte schon, reicht's aber, ich bin jetzt nicht, also ich habe nur Schlaufe, mir geht's ja gut.
Und so, und ohne Schlaufe wird man behandelt, wird umhergestossen und so und in Hagen auf die Gleise geworfen und dann kommt der Schaffner und spuckt dir ins Gesicht. Das ist halt der harte Umgang. Ja, das ist die schlaufenlose Welt, ja, ja. Aber das meine ich, das sind die Dinge, um die man sich, also, lass uns doch mal Streckenausbau, lass uns über das fehlende Internet und so, das sind doch alles die viel größeren Baustellen als der Ruhrabteil. Die Steckdosen. Steckdosen funktionieren. Ich hatte letztens wirklich einen ganz interessanten Kampf über Stunden hinweg, so eine junge Frau sass neben mir mit leerem Handy, ich sass neben ihr mit leerem Laptop und es gibt nur eine Steckdose. Und der alte Kampf, Handy versus Laptop. Genau, ich hatte die Steckdose erstmal in Besitz und dann packte sie so das Ladegerät aus und ich natürlich zuvor komme, ah, okay, ja, nehmen sie ruhig die Steckdose. Im Laufe der Zeit hat er natürlich immer weiter die Prozente runter, ich schließe schon Textedit irgendwie, ich schaue nur noch YouTube-Videos, nur noch von meiner Festplatte. Sehr gut, dass du dich dann gegen Textedit entscheidest.est. Mach alles zu. Und dann irgendwann kommt die Nachricht, kein Akku mehr. Ich habe versucht, sogar den Laptop so zu drehen, dass sie die Nachricht sehen kann mit keinem Akku mehr. Dass sie vielleicht dann, ah, so durch. Und die gesamte Fahrt war es echt ein Hin und Her, weil ich hatte das Gefühl ... Aber warst du so draufgezeigt, ah, ah, jetzt schon wieder ... Ah, jetzt habe ich noch irgendwo Batterien rumliegen oder was mache ich jetzt? Viel Kram und viel Suchen mit dem Stecker versuchen, so Empfang zu bekommen. Stecker so in die Luft, gegen das Fenster, kann ich hier irgendwo den Fahrtwind ... Hat jemand so ein Windrad? Windgenerator. Entschuldigung, hat jemand ein Windrad? Das ist das Ruheabteil. Haben Sie die Petition nicht gegeben? Ich weiß!
Sie sind Florentin-Vell.
Dass du irgendwann so jünger hast im Ruheabteil.
Bist du nicht Florentin?
Pst, ja, bin ich.
Ich bin der grösste Fan.
Aber wie kann es sein, dass du hier rumschreist im Ruheabteil?
Naja, ich habe gerade noch eine andere Sache am Laufen mit den Steckdosen.
Das ist mehr Steckdosen.
Jetzt muss ich hier ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit.
Aber in deiner Petition steht doch, dass es nichts Wichtiges gibt als die Stimme. Du meinst doch, dass du lieber nicht ankommen willst, als ein lautenes Ruheabteil zu ertragen. Das sind Dinge, die sagt man, wenn man die Petition voranbringen will. Du warst unser grösster Held, der Messias, der Obi-Wan Kenobi. Ich bin auch Politiker, ich muss auch ein bisschen das realpolitisch umsetzen können, aber hier ist die nächste Petition, zwei Steckdosen. Nee, ich will Stille. Ich will die liebste Stille. Aber du gibst mir doch recht, wärst du lieber über neun Stunden unterwegs? Ich lasse mich gar nicht auf dein Whataboutism hier ein, dass du hier versuchst, von den kleinen Problemen abzulenken, indem du mit deinen lächerlichen, grossen Problemen kommst. Kleine Probleme haben auch ihre Berechtigung. Das sage ich ja gar nicht. Kleine Probleme bedürfen manchmal auch kleine Lösungen und nicht gar keine Lösungen. Ich war der grösste Fürredner, ich bin der erste Unterzeichner gewesen. Was ich nur sagen möchte, und es ist auch kein Modobotism, wir reden ja über das gleiche Unternehmen und ähnliche Probleme, nämlich viele Baustellen in diesem kleinen Unternehmen, in diesem riesengroßen Unternehmen, viele kleine Baustellen. Aber ich möchte nur sagen, es gibt doch wirklich andere Dinge, auf die wir uns erstmal fokussieren sollten. Bist du nicht der Meinung, dass es erstmal darum gehen sollte, ans Ziel zu kommen in der vorgesehenen Zeit? Du, ich habe mich jetzt politisch festgelegt, ich habe die Partei... Aber ärgerst du dich, dass du dich dahin festgelegt hast? Das ist natürlich jetzt gar nichts zur Sache. Unsere Partei schaut nach vorne, nicht nach hinten. Wir versuchen nicht, irgendwelche alten Fehler jetzt hier aufzukauen. Ihre Partei schaut nur auf das Schild, auf dem Stilpst. Unsere Partei schaut in Fahrtrichtung. Ja, das ist das Wichtige. Und deswegen, Reue gibt es sowas nicht. Reue gibt es in der Geschichte gar nicht. Okay, also Vorsicht zusammen, Sie wollen lieber eine ruhige Fahrt genießen als eine Fahrt mit Ziel. Ja, ja. Okay, alles klar. Dann haben Sie meine Stimme nicht. Ich habe mich entschlossen, ich bin der Moderator dieser Sendung. Herr Zimmer, wie gesagt, Sie können nicht Leute einladen nur für eine Frage. Ne, ne, Sie haben mich nicht. So wäre ich nämlich. Ich weiss, Anneville und so, die kriegen das immer so gut hin, dass sie dann ausgewogen Fragen stellen und so. Und im Kopf switchen die immer alle Schalter. Und dann sind sie fast neutral, dass ihre Persönlichkeit hinter diesen Schaltern verschwindet. Und ich wäre da so nicht. Ich bin da so, wenn ich True-Crime-Sachen gucke, sehr schnell begeisterbar für eine Seite. Und dann würde ich wahrscheinlich mit mir so was rausrutschen wie, das hat mich jetzt gar nicht überzeugt, das will ich nicht mehr sie. Ich habe das Problem, dass ich bei Gesprächen oft so rausdrifte und ich glaube, ich wäre als Talkshow-Haus eher so ein, können Sie noch mal sagen, ich habe jetzt gerade überhaupt gar nichts zugehört. So, I zoned out. Nichts ging sehr, ich habe gerade überhaupt nicht zugehört. Oder auch so die ganzen Begriffigkeiten. Was bedeutet das? Was meinen Sie? Aus Auslage, Umlage? Sorry, bin ich der Einzige, der hier gerade gar nichts versteht? Ganze Publikum schüttelt den Kopf. Ach so, bin ich der? Ja, ja, ist das Problem. Können Sie es für mich noch einmal kurz erklären? Die Umlagepolitik der
EZB
führt zu einer
Inflation,
jetzt sagen Sie noch mal ganz kurz,
die Europäische Zentralbank,
führt zu einer
Inflationspolitik,
die seit der grossen Rezession
nicht mehr
gesehen ward.
Okay.
Gut, jetzt, wenn ich den Satz noch mal
wiederhole, fällt mir auf, ich kann den auch
Vielen Dank. nicht mehr gesehen ward. Okay. Gut, jetzt, wenn ich den Satz noch mal wiederhole, fällt mir auf,
ich kann den auch einfacher verständlich ausdrücken.
Ja.
Haben Sie da keine Frage?
Hat sonst noch jemand was, was er unbedingt unterbringen will?
Was unbedingt noch gesagt werden muss?
Das ist immer mein Lieblingsmoment.
Aber dann wärst du der beste Moderator für Funkformate. Oh, yes, yes. was unbedingt noch gesagt werden muss. Das ist immer mein Lieblingsmoment.
Aber dann wärst du der beste Moderator für Funk-Formate. Oh, yes, yes, yes, Shots fired, passende Shots, mega gut formuliert, Shots fired, take that, take that. Everybody, Ruhe jetzt! Okay, aber du freust dich, heisst du freust dich gar nicht auf dein Spotify-Jahresrubis? A-D-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R-R- Mal schauen, in welche Richtung es geht. Ich nehme ja immer Vorsätze fürs nächste Jahr, die ich dann aber relativ schnell wieder vergesse.
Aber bist du auch so ein Jahresrückblick-Fan? Ja, ja, ja, total. Freust du dich darauf? Generell, das wäre, glaube ich, noch so ein Feature, wo, also jetzt, wenn wir mal denken über dieses ganze Themenfeld, Augmented Reality, Virtual Reality, Brille, all das, ja, das digitalisierte Leben, der digitalisierte Alltag im Allgemeinen. Da würde ich ja sagen, klar, die Ängste, die Vorsicht, ja, Werbung überall, wer greift da ein, wer kontrolliert die Algorithmen, ja, aber was ich gerne hätte, wäre so eine Art Rückblick, so eine Art Statistik, dass der Computer wirklich mitschreibt und am Ende des Jahres so viele Tassen Tee getrunken, so viele Stufen Treppe gelaufen, so oft das Wort Marienkäfer benutzt, ja top, die häufigst benutzten Wörter. Das würde ich so gern haben. Alle Datenkraken, die mit denen wir so zu tun haben, sammeln ja so viel über uns, die wissen doch, bei welchem Wort habe ich mich am meisten verschrieben. Das hilft ja auch für die Zukunft. Ja, aber das ist doch auch progressiv. Der häufigst gemachte Witz in Chat-Konversationen bei WhatsApp. Ja. Das wäre doch immer geil. Emojis verwendet, falsch geschrieben, Dramatikfehler. Das waren die Sätze, wo du statistisch gesehen bei Tinder am wenigsten Rückmeldungen bekommen hast. Ja, genau. So was. Und da würde ich mich wirklich am Ende des Jahres so irgendwie am 29. oder so. Das war das Bild bei Tinder, wo du am häufigsten weggeswipet warst. Genau, ja, sowas. Das sind die Gründe bei Tinder, weswegen du keinen Erfolg bei Frauen hast. Das sind die Top-Gesichtsausdrücke von Frauen, wenn sie dein Bild gesehen haben beim Swipen. Das kann man ja alles kriegen. Tinder-Roast-Stefan. Das kann man ja alles machen. Hier sind 95 Thesen, warum du die App verlassen solltest, you idiot. Ja, das würde ich so gerne machen, so mit einem Glas Glühwein am Lagerfeuer sitzen und dann diesen großen Ordner durchschlagen einfach, wo einfach nochmal alles drinsteht. Wie oft Schlüssel verloren, wie viel Zeit geduscht, wie viel Zeit gar nichts gemacht einfach, durchschnittliche Schlafdauer, am längsten, am kürzesten, sowas. Google könnte auch deine grössten Google-Fails dieses Jahr oder sowas. Oder generell. Weil die sehen ja doch auch, die wissen doch auch, was du reinschreibst, bevor du auf Enter reichst. Da würde ich mal gerne sehen, wer hat das am meisten geändert? Ja. So, und dann hat am Ende was, wer kam ganz woanders raus am Anfang, vorm Enter, als er am Anfang eigentlich intendiert hatte. Er fing an bei Kolumbus Limbus Wolken und hat aufgehört bei Geierperlhuhn. So, das will ich ja auch sehen. Wer hat da weirde Suchanfragen gestartet? Ja, das bräuchte man, wirklich so Alltagsstatistiken. Ich würde mich da richtig reinlegen, ich würde mich da richtig daran ergötzen einfach.
Wie viele Stufen gehst du pro Tag?
Tja.
Viele Sachen kannst du einfach auch ausrechnen.
Hundert vielleicht am Tag?
Hundert Treppenstufen pro Tag.
Wie viele Stufen hat denn so ein klassischer Abschnitt?
Vierzehn. Vierzehn Stufen haben, glaube ich, so durchschnittlich, sagen wir mal, ein Stockwerk.
Ja, dann vierzehn. Ist ja genormt, weil es gibt ja so Treppen, so Gagtreppen, die der Norm nicht entsprechen, und man ist sofort irritiert, man geht ja komisch hoch und runter. Und haben Sie bereut, dass Sie in Ihrem Haus eine Gagtreppe eingebaut haben? Ja, ja. Also am Anfang fand ich es lustig. Wie lange war das lustig? Zwei Tage. Zwei Tage lang fanden Sie es lustig, dass Sie gestolpert sind bei einer Stufe, die etwas kleiner war? Ja, also ich fand es dann nicht mehr lustig. Also spätestens auch, als dann Frau Meierling zu Tode kam. Die war schon ein bisschen älter. Wir haben das Treppenhaus saniert, ich habe diesen Gag eingebaut und plötzlich höchst Rumpeln im Flur und... Na, ich kam, zu spät. Schrecklich, schrecklich. Was ist ein Lachen wert? Gut, sie ist auch rückblickend dann an meinem Prank-Einweihungsgeschenk, war ja auch nicht ganz unbeteiligt. Da habe ich ihr diesen Kuchen gebacken mit einem Ring drin. Als Art Fake-Heiratsantrag oder wie? Genau so als, nein, der war eigentlich für meine Freundin, oh, jetzt haben sie den Ring bekommen. Oh, die Freundin hat den mit dem Gift bekommen oder so. Oh, jetzt hat meine Freundin den mit dem Gift bekommen, das war also kein Scherz gedacht. Sie lachen gern, ne? Ich wollte sagen, ja, ich bin ein Prankster, aber jetzt rückblickend bin ich sehr ernst geworden, weil viele Pranks ... Hat sie das verändert, dieser Tod von Frau Meierling? Ja, nicht nur der Tod, also es waren viele Tode. Jetzt muss man aber sagen, der Obduktionsbericht hat ergeben, dass sie gestürzt ist, die Treppe herunter und unten an der Treppe, wo sie dann gelandet ist, da ein Furzkissen lag. Das schien ja schon präpariert dorthin gelegt worden zu sein.
Können Sie dazu was sagen?
Es irritiert mich jetzt ein bisschen, weil es beißt sich mit dem anderen Obduktionsbericht,
der sagte, dass der
Stromschocker an der
Türklinke vielleicht zu
doll.
Ich habe den nicht wie, man sollte den an so einer
9-Volt-Batterie, hatte ich nicht, jetzt habe ich den an so einen
Generator angeschlossen, dachte mir,
vielleicht so ein bisschen stärker. Sie hatte also den Ring im Hals, keuchend hat sie die Klinke angefasst, dadurch ist sie von der Treppe zurückgestossen worden. Auf die Treppe hat dort den Halt verloren wegen der lustigen Stufe, stürzte die Treppe herab auf das bereitgelegte Furzkisten, ein lautes Pupsgeräusch entstand. Das war diese spezielle Furzkisten, das habe ich in Japan bestellt. Als die Feuerwehr, also die Krankenwagen bereits eintraf, hat es noch gefurzt. Und sie kam rein, die Krankenwagen, und dann hatte ich noch diesen Wassereimer oben platziert. Klar, rückblickend ist es einfach eine unglückliche Geschichte, aber der Wassereimer ist dann über den Ersthelfer, über den Sanitäter gegangen. Der wurde dann auch noch gefedert und da sind ein paar Federn runtergekommen. Das gönnt jetzt hier auch dann nicht mehr. Es hieß ja, dass das die Rettungsmassnahmen stark beeinträchtigt hat und ansonsten Frau Meiling vielleicht noch hätte leben können. Gut, das ist Spekulation. Ich war mal, man merkt, ich bin ... Ja, wo kommen Sie beruflich her? Das würde mich jetzt auch interessieren. Clown. Sie waren Clown. Vier Jahre lang die Clown-Schule besucht, Master, Master gemacht dann noch im Clownismus, Bachelor-Klassisch BWL. Aber rückblickend war das vielleicht ein Fehler. Also meine Prankster- Laufbahn, gut, die möchte ich denn hiermit jetzt auch beenden. Waren das die letzten Pranks, die Sie begangen haben, oder was machen Sie seitdem? Das hat mich zurückgezogen. Privatier, aber ohne Geld, was es nicht einfach macht, Privatier zu werden. Ja, Sie sehen sehr emotional mitgenommen aus von der ganzen Sache. Da hat man fast das Gefühl, das Lachen ist Ihnen vergangen. Ich würde Ihnen gerne zum Abschluss die Hand geben und Sie verabschieden. Haben Sie keine Angst. Sie können mir einfach die Hand geben. Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie haben sich geändert. Und ich glaube Ihnen, dass Sie sehen sehr emotional aus, die ganze Geschichte hat sie mitgenommen.
Vielen, vielen Dank, dass Sie heute da waren.
Bogo, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bogo Bozo.
Ah, meine Hand!
Ah!
Wie kleiner Prankster.
Ah, das tut richtig weh, das brennt.
Ah, ich kann meine Hand nicht mehr bewegen. Entschuldige, wir müssen hier abbrechen. Haben wir eine Schlaufe? Kann ich eine Schlaufe haben? Nee, das soll doch so ein Prank sein. Kann ich vielleicht eine Schlaufe haben? Ja, hier wird gerade der Kicker geliefert. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitbekommt, aber wir kriegen gerade den Kicker geliefert. Wir wollen ja so ein bisschen unser Studio ein bisschen aufpeppen. Stefan hat sich den Wasserspender gewünscht, ich habe den Kicker gewünscht und jetzt kannst du immer was trinken, während ich Kicker spiele. Genau, was natürlich für Aufnahmen perfekt ist. Das Gluckern werdet ihr euch daran gewöhnen müssen, das Gluckern des Wasserspenders. Wir haben Snackautomaten mit ganz vielen verschiedenen bunten Papiertütchen. Wir haben den Schlüssel nicht für das Kleingeldfach, um das zu nähern. Das heißt, wir machen aktuell noch Verlust. Danke an unsere Clubmitglieder auch. Genau, euer Geld weist sich in sicheren Händen. In dieser Stahlbox da unten drin. Bis wir die rauskriegen, kann die auch überlaufen. Ich denke schon, ja, also ich denke, es ist einfach verstopft. Also könnte sich nicht eine ganze Schule zusammentun und sagen, wir kaufen so viele Snacks, bis die Kleingeld-Truhe zu ist, sodass das dann wieder rausfällt. Nein, nein, nein. Überläuft und dann kann man kostenlos kaufen. Wenn es überlaufen würde, könnte man ja auch reingreifen und das klauen. Oh, oh. Da glaube ich, hat auch noch mal jemand mitzureden, wenn es um Diebstahl geht. Also Gott. Oh oh. Gott ist ja nicht allmächtiger Vater. Wir haben über Kirchenaustritte gesprochen. Aber du bist ja nicht gleich die Institution, allmächtiger Vater. Du bist ja nicht gleich die ... ne, das wollen wir ...
Wir wollen aus der Institution heraus, weil die macht Schindluder.
Gott, so höre doch auf!
Ist ja gerade ein Frosch vom Himmel gefallen.
Scheiße.
Nee, das Wasser, blutrot, der Fluss.
Stefan, du hättest nicht austreten dürfen. Mehr Plagen, sag mehr Plagen. Du hättest nicht auftreten, denn Heuschrecken überall. Okay, nice, nice, nice, mehr Plagen, mehr Plagen. Rinder, missgestaltete Rinder mit zwei Köpfen. Und die Erstgeborenen sterben. Schau, alle Erstgeborenen sterben. Alle Erst, oh nein, Heinrich, Heinrich. Ich bin auch erstgeboren. Oh nein. Stefan, sag mir jetzt noch schnell, soll ich den Podcast weitermachen, nachdem du tot bist oder nicht? Nein, nein, du sollst den nicht weitermachen. Mach einen anderen Podcast. Okay. Will ich den Podcast hier weitermachen? Okay. Ist doch scheiße. Jetzt haben wir es auf Tape. Jetzt haben wir es auf Tape. Vielleicht hätte ich einfach nicht fragen sollen und danach einfach sagen sollen, Stefan wollte unbedingt, dass ich den Podcast weiterführe. Und in dem Moment Gling, Dong, Ding. Du hast einen Anruf, im Himmel hat man so einen Anruf, du darfst einmal, Gott sagt so, ja, du darfst einmal anrufen, du darfst einmal eingreifen. Aber darf ich einmal alle Glocken auswählen oder darf ich nur einmal die Glocken? Ach Gott, eine Glocken. Doch, doch, doch, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, nein, doch, ist doch in Ordnung. Guck mal, sei doch vor, dass du überhaupt einen Anruf bekommst. Du darfst einmal eine Glocke läuten lassen, wenn du es brauchst. Warum ist es wie amerikanische Gefängnisse? Warum ist der Himmel wie ein amerikanisches Gefängnis? Wir haben hier relativ viel aus der amerikanischen Kultur übernommen, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Ich bin ein großer Fan, deswegen tragen hier auch alle Jeans mit diesen ganz kleinen Taschen, damit da auch ein paar Gutscheine reinpassen für die Popcornmaschine. Ich bin großer Fan der Serie The Bear, die kam jetzt von ein paar Wochen raus, liebe ich sehr. Es geht nicht um einen Bären. Es geht nicht um einen Bären, es geht um einen Koch, der ein Old Cuisine-Koch, der den Sandwich-Shop, den Italian-Sandwich-Shop seines Bruders übernimmt. Ganz, ganz tolle Idee, toll gemacht, hat mir wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht, aber der heimliche Star, da haben jetzt unfassbar viele Kulturmagazine drüber geschrieben, der New Yorker, das SZ-Magazin, Zeitmagazine, haben drüber geschrieben, dass der heimliche Star das Shirt ist, das weisse Shirt von diesem sehr attraktiven Koch, der trägt die ganze Zeit nur Blue Jeans und dieses weisse, megacoole Shirt, dieses Marlon Brando Shirt. Also der Homer Simpson-Look sozusagen. Eigentlich der Homer Simpson, der trägt ja mit Polohemd. Aber, oder nicht? Normales Hemd, glaube ich. Mit Kragen und Brustasche. Das ist jedenfalls ein ganz normales T-Shirt und das habe ich mir jetzt bestellt, weil alle haben dann versucht herauszufinden, wer der Hersteller dieses fantastischen Shirts ist. Und es ist eine deutsche Firma, eine Berliner Firma, die heißt Merz bei Schwanen, eine uralte Firma, die irgendwie seit den Fünfzigern oder noch davor angefangen hat, so Arbeitsteigungen herzustellen. Die haben halt dieses weisse Shirt in diesem dicken Stoff gemacht und stellen das immer noch so her. Das heißt, T-Shirt 1950. Und das habe ich mir jetzt bestellt. Ich will mal gucken, wie ich darin aussehe. Das heißt, du kombinierst jetzt gerade eine Serienempfehlung mit einer T-Shirt-Empfehlung. Mit einer Fashion-Empfehlung. Weil, tragt liebe, liebe, liebe Jungs und Mädels, tragt mir doch weisse Shirts und Hose, Jeans, sieht super aus.
Gerade, falsche Jahreszeit dafür, falsche Jahreszeit. Darüber müsst ihr noch einen Pulli anziehen und dicke Jacke und darüber noch einen Schal und Mütze, dass man euch nicht mehr sieht und ihr alle modisch nicht mehr von uns unterscheiden seid. Weil alle sehen aus wie Maggie Simpson im Winter. Extremitäten von sich gespreizt, weil dicke Daunen im Weg sind. Aber, ne, dass ihr mir im Sommer nicht vergesst, The Bear tragt ein geiles, cooles, festes, schwarzes Schirr. Ich habe gerade Babylon Berlin Staffel 4 gesehen und überlegt, ob ich mir einen Hut anschaffen soll. Eine Fedora? Jesus Christ. Na, das ist schon cool, wie der eine so einen Hut, den kann man so kann man immer so ziehen und so einen Hut abnehmen, wenn was passiert und so.
Das ist schon cool. Nee, ist nicht so cool.
Nee, meinst du nicht mit so einem coolen Mantel
und so und an so einer Marke
und so, eine Krawatte oder so,
nicht mit so einem Hut? Nein, das ist verkleidet aus.
Also du machst so schöne Haare,
zeig deine Haare, zeig deine lockigen Haare,
zeig die.
Das ist, nein, also da wollen wir jetzt nicht mit anfangen. Nee, aber so ein Cape wäre gut für dich. So ein grosses Cape? Ein Cape. Aber keinen Umhang. Nee, ein Cape. Ja? Ja. Das fände ich super. Ich überleg's mir. Ich glaube, ich muss mich dieses nächste Jahr modisch neu erfinden. Also 2023 können wir am Anfang noch mal drüber reden. Ich will mich neu erfinden, ich weiß noch nicht, in welche Richtung es geht, sondern ich plane so ein paar prototypische Richtungen, in die es gehen könnte, aber vielleicht, falls ihr Ideen habt, gerne Lux, Persönlichkeiten auch. Ich bin frei, ich bin völlig offen. Puma, Hunter, alles könnt ihr gerne machen. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine schöne Woche und viel Spass mit all den Dingen, die jetzt kommen, der herrliche November mit all seinen Früchten und Freuden. Ja, und der ganzen Sonne und dem Früchten, also das ist wirklich nicht, wofür November steht. Also viel Spaß mit euren Herbstdepressionen, Laub und der Dunkelheit, die uns alle umgibt. Macht's gut, wir steigen ein, wir heben ab. Tschau!